hey guys I'm Jess McDonald it's the 17th
of January and you're joining me for
your top 5 weekly dose of GameSpot news
now I know it sounds scary when I call
it a dose but don't worry we'll be
gentle let's get into it
not too long ago Sony was saying that
they don't care about the sales
comparison data between the ps4 and the
Xbox one and now Microsoft is saying
they reckon the hardware differences
between the consoles aren't so
significant Microsoft have called the
differences in specifications fairly
marginal and while they agree purists
are likely to argue that point they've
said what it really comes down to is the
games the publisher have said that the
Xbox one's exclusives will pull them up
and above the ps4 Xbox New Zealand leads
Steven Blackburn also said that the Xbox
one is absolutely as male and court
skewed as you can imagine although he
anticipates change in this demographic
do you agree with Microsoft's statements
here and do you think the ps4 and the
Xbox one do have significant differences
in hardware let me know indie developer
Jason Brewer reckons that things like
Steam sales are bad for players and devs
alike the one man team behind passage
and sleep is death has proposed that
sales make gamers who pay full price
feel like they've been taken for a ride
and since they occur so frequently most
consumers are likely to hold off on
paying full price well yeah but rora
thinks this creates a weaker smaller
player community at launch for his new
game the Castle Doctrine rora has said
he'll use the ever-rising model inspired
by a Minecraft we're buying the Alpha
will set you back $8 $12 during launch
week and a full price of $16 off to
words do you see any method to this
madness or is it simply madness
battlefield 4 has received PC ps3 and
ps4 updates for the relief of its
frustrated players but is it too little
too late the large scale military
shooter which has gathered quite a fair
bit of hate and conscience
see due to its numerous bugs has
undergone many sizeable fixes for the
three platforms that are all set to
eight in general stability and assist in
the rectification of balance issues
believe it or not that is actually a
word you can find the complete list of
fixes on GameSpot but let me know in the
comments whether you've given up on
battlefield 4 already or if you're happy
to see that dice are delivering on these
solely needed patches in news of other
things that are likely too little too
late we're ten months on and finally
being offered an offline mode for
SimCity which we asked for almost a year
ago Maxis has promised all your
previously downloaded content and saves
will still be available to you in the
upcoming tenth update which beaches
offline play Maxis are hoping the mode
will not only sate people like me who
aren't fans of always online but also
encouraged the modding community to go
nuts without worrying about messing up
their online game is the offline mode
likely to make you go back too soon city
or not you can leave me your thoughts in
the comments last of the March today
we've got some more info on the Last of
Us a DLC which is now making me realize
that I probably should have started this
segment with a less confusing intro the
single-player expansion called Left
Behind has been described by Ellie's
voice actor Ashley Johnson as more
playful than the main game which
shouldn't be particularly difficult
given the heart-wrenching original the
DLC which is set before the events of
the last of us will be available on
February 14 and we'll deal with Ellie
and the friend Riley just two girls
hanging out in the apocalypse you know
how it is what are your current levels
of excitement for the DLC mediocre
extreme none you can let me know in the
comments down below or on my Twitter
where I'm at just mcdonald this week on
site check out johnny's advice on how to
prepare yourself through the Elder
Scrolls online in
the waiting game check out my list of
the best sidekicks ever in the gist and
hear what Danny has to say about digital
game sales on the point also we have
some shows that don't start with there
but I don't remember what they are
that's it for this week's lot of games
but news that be sure to join me again
next week for a whole lot more bits and
pieces and estimate all and I'll see you
again next week